welcome to your mom's house
I can sing like this I can sing just
like Rihanna and
all right let's move it along no I guess
no it's good I'm saying it's good let me
hear you sing it if you haven't picked
up Rihanna's new album it's been playing
in the Segura house all weekend couple
months old you're the musical 12-year
old or whatever yeah
Rehana I guarantee we talked about this
she didn't write those lyrics right that
was written by a fat too old music
producer record guy the record labels
like you know what you should do a song
about how fucking your soul mate thing
is I've always wanted to fuck you
exactly
second I saw you I saw those that thin
like chocolate frame and I wanted to
break it in half about how great it is
to fuck you right cuz that no woman is
like I'm gonna write a song called sex
with me is so amazing and then she just
is this what you wrote yeah all right
yeah let's go how much am I getting paid
on this deal oh okay yeah it's amazing
fucking me is amazing it's crazy
no women don't and also like it's clunky
where she's like stay up off my
Instagram this so temptation because the
guys like I look at your Instagram every
day when I drag off all over my house
yeah great there's no rhyming in that
Rihanna album no is it in many weeks in
a row
wow this dog shit yeah that is pure shit
really you don't like that I like it no
it's like it's like 12 year old girls
listen to that shit in you and my
husband my 48 year old husband until